quant à l'accusée il ne perd rien de sa
superbe le chef des serbes de bosnie
s'offre même le luxe de prendre une
initiative
radovan karadic se dit prêt à négocier
une démilitarisation de sarajevo
jacques merlino a réussi à le joindre
d'amusement oui l'état au culot de nous
avons prévu dans le cadre des
dispositions générales destinées à faire
régner la paix en bosnie à sarajevo en
particulier il veut placer sarajevo sous
le contrôle de la forpronu pendant 30
ans mais nous estimons que ça y est vous
seul doit tomber sous le contrôle de
l'onu
ce qui est important pour nous c'est de
garantir la sécurité des partis serbes
de la ville pour éviter les massacres
qui ont déjà eu lieu dans les eaux ne
peut bien que les serbes
nous avons l'intention de faire tout
notre possible pour que cela c'est pour
que les arrangements soient mis en
oeuvre
est-ce que vous acceptez de reculer vos
pièces d'artillerie et de les placer
sous le contrôle de l'onu l'a retiré
musulmane et au cas où la paix régnerait
à sarajevo sera contrôlé par la force
onu au lieu choisi par celle ci cela dit
il n'est pas possible de retirer
complètement l'artillerie serbe
nous sommes pour la paix mais les
musulmans ne sont pas pour la paix les
yoffois poursuivre la guerre et il faut
donc que l'on garantisse que les
musulmans aussi retire leur artillerie
lourde
comment les responsables bosniaques
réagiront-ils à cette proposition
rejoignant en direct de sarajevo notre
envoyé spécial le jean-jacques le garrec
peuvent-ils croire à la sincérité de
karachi jack savez les bosniaques ont
l'habitude de ce genre de déclarations
d'un côté vous avez monsieur boutros
ghali à l'onu qui demande à ce que l'on
réfléchisse à la possibilité d'une
intervention aérienne et à sa mise en
place et puis de l'autre côté au même
moment vous avez monsieur karadzic qui
se dit prêt à accepter une
démilitarisation de sarajevo en personne
née d'un côté d'accord sur la manière de
faire cette intervention aérienne et
personne ne sait très bien ce que veut
dire exactement une des militaires
lisa sion de sarajevo monsieur karadzic
le disais à l'instant cette
démilitarisation de sarajevo il ne peut
pas se retirer complètement dit il donc
un retrait qui ne serait pas complet
qu'est ce que cela peut amener donc à
chaque fois c'est le retour à la case
départ
on revient au même point et à chaque
fois on regagne du temps sur une
situation sur un statu quo qui signifie
bombardements quotidiens
jean-jacques vous qui êtes à sarajevo
depuis des mois que se passera-t-il s'il
n'y a pas d'intervention militaire
internationale il est difficile
aujourd'hui pour les gens de sarajevo et
pour la bosnie d'imaginer que l'on
puisse aboutir à une situation sans
passer par la force tout a été à peu
près essayé dans ce qui est possible de
faire et toutes les négociations ont été
à peu près essayez donc aujourd'hui s'il
n'y a pas un moment ou un autre un
emploi d'une vraie force et on parle
évidemment comme force de l'intervention
aérienne
on ne vois pas à part encore de gagner
du temps et de gagner du temps que je
vous le dis à nouveau veux dire ici un
statu quo meurtrier
on ne voit pas comment on pourrait
sortir de cette de cette situation merci
jean jacques l'heure